bienvenue j'ai envie de vous dire
bienvenue sur face book cuisine cuisine
je fais ma petite puis franchement ce
serait où ce qu'ils trouvent
j'espère qu'il va trouver après bon j'ai
un peu embrouillé déjà toujours à
contrer en fin de vidéo quand la recette
ça va être délicieux dans le froid
cuisiner sur motion l'animation facebook
cuisine est ternie salut à vous peuple d
internet aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour
la première fois en 500 vidéos de la
chaîne dans ma cuisine
ceci est ma cuisine ici je me nourris je
fais à manger et ghf avec moi j'ai pas
n'importe quel chef
j'efface goût de cuisine ou un bon gars
et le défi aujourd'hui ça va être de
trouver sa recette
tu va proposer un truc génial c'est à
dire j'avais une idée de recette à faire
ensemble et tu t'es dit ok mais que si
je devine la recette way pour la
première fois de ma liste parce que je
regarde des vidéos je me suis bon qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire avec toi du
coup et là je suis pro mais il faut
qu'il devienne une recette s'il arrive à
faire ça c'est exceptionnel je devine et
pas mal de choses sur cette chaîne des
films des musiques et machin des gémeaux
l'oas et mot de passe et tout par contre
une recette la cuisine c'est pas un
domaine que je maîtrise de ouf
t'as pas les ingrédients moi je pensais
vraiment qu'on allait faire cette vidéo
que j'allais te présenter un peu les
ingrédients auchan etc
enfin une liste d'ingrédients et que toi
tu puisses te donner pis là on part
vraiment de gros alors on part de rien
et je me dis les ingrédients à précidé
joker si je galère de ouf je manquais
vas-y de moine à des ingrédients
principaux le brin d'aillet roussillon
on va pouvoir le faire ça et je sais que
pour l'instant je pars de mézin regret à
tous et que c'est en deux mots je sais
que c'est un plat salé
parce que a priori c'est sale et quand
je regarde ta tête auquel on est
d'accord et je sais que ça se cuisine
dit qu'est ce que tu m'as dit que tu
avais
un peu sur traille mais je sais qu'on
est prise exactement le premier truc
c'est que pour l'instant quand je t'ai
parlé d'une recette s'alléger
l'étonnement
donc j'ai un point de départ où je me
dis ok c'est peut-être pas salé et
peut-être que tu m'as envoyé la tête je
suis d'abord de trouver la lettre du
premier mort aux verts comme ça ça va me
donner à bonnac sting toi t'as juste à
penser la laine du premier mot quand je
la dirai tu dira stop quand on espère qu
est ce que tu peux regarder l'écran même
temps parce que je sais que vous voulez
essayer de le faire maintenant que moi
je pense juste à la première lettre
et quand je la dis tu dis stop dans tata
motors
[Musique]
ça peut être a b c d e f
ok j'ai un relâchement ici ça veut dire
que ça passait donc dans des luttes et
ça ça veut dire oui oui je commence à
avoir un petit peu de de matière à
mentaliser chargé ces deux puisque comme
je suis une vidéo nous tac tac tac tac
tac je suis et c'est rien aura lâché
mais en fait je relâche malgré cela ok
je pense même savoir laquelle c'est un
petit doute sur le sel qui suit mais je
pense avoir la peine est-ce que je te le
dis ou pas pour l'instant pourquoi je te
le dis mais tu réagis pas forcément ok
je sais ce que tu veux je pense que
c'est un s'est élargie pas forcément car
mais tu devrais travailler dans les
services et crèmes onguents une recette
salée saône recettes sucrées
oui alors est ce que vous venez de voir
ça s'appelle un clown asthme physique
c'est-à-dire il ya un des deux sur
lequel il a acquiescé et c'était super
je me fais un but de la tête sur sucre
est un génie dave ouais je suis même pas
rendu compte donc c'est comment se
passer et c'est une recette sucrée d'un
victimes de pêche c'est du poulet un
gars restée pour moi j'annonce que j'ai
envoyé une liste d'ingrédients mais y'a
pas tout jeter
c'est génial je brave au hockey de dupes
où les mangas
comment tu peux penser une recette
sucrée de mo minimum qui commence par
ainsi qu'une recette super ok maintenant
je vais faire des questions de
déductions à laquelle tu dois me
répondre sincèrement parce que tu as
déjà fait une recette de ce genre sur ta
chaîne wii
la même recette non non est ce que l'un
des ingrédients est un ingrédient que tu
utilises souvent sur sa chaîne oui ok
d'accord c'est un ingrédient qu'on mange
c'est un aplat du rhdp tout le monde
aime je dirais 408 jamie alcom est
l'ingrédient ouais c'est mieux quand
même
en fait je ne sais pas parler parce que
si je te dis un truc bien si je vais me
mets moi je fais ce que j'ai à faire
fais ce que tu as peur parce que j'ai à
faire quelque chose qui commence par un
c est qui d'après moi quand il ya
d'unités la paume et killian roger qui
monte
en fait si c'est la différence entre un
vrai sourire à un sourire devrait
sourire on a les pommettes clairement
tenez on plisse ici le fait que tu es un
vrai sourire ça me donne aussi des
informations sur cas jeudi en fait ok je
vais essayer d'avoir la deuxième lettre
en pensant à faire du cul berlin 10 mhz
tu vas me donner ton bras comme ça et
puis si je regarde pas son visage nous
qui pensent à la deuxième lettre de ton
premier vo ça peut être a b c d e f g h
i j book
lmnb restent élevés du public chez
greenedge l'époque a b c d e f g h i j
qu elle ok je pense que c'est un lâche
alors je dis pas que c'est sain mais
pour l'instant je pense à de la
chantilly dit la championne idée là vous
appelez existé qu'est-ce qui existe
d'autres comme ça je pense que peut-être
il ya des gens qui ont déjà des pistes
c'est vrai tu penses que eux ils peuvent
tous ok si vous avez trouvé avant moi
dites le moi dans les commentaires si
vous avez trouvé avant moi je serais
curieux de voir statistiquement combien
de personnes n'ont déjà donc ça veut
dire que mes éléments sont bons c'était
donc ça veut dire que là c'est plus que
de la séduction en fait la partie
mentalisme
dana lisa les fêtes et maintenant c'est
à dire sans déduction on peut trouver ça
un citroën brel charles de gaulle ceux
qui ont regardé je comprendrais faire
j'en ai un pour les marchés mais je me
dis en termes d'éléments de cuisine tu
m'as pas après un gros cinq carats qui
ont donné des trucs on utilise de
l'huile qu'on fait frire oui les churros
honnêteté la yes zaoui pas y aller
franchement tu es super bass havas que
tu m'as tu as fait un truc trop
compliqué que tu vois genre mes recettes
des familles comme je disais à la
brocante étaient hors caméra qui
essaient de brouiller avec le poulet que
je me suis je te donne quelques
ingrédients aussi guadeloupe ou qui font
vraiment que j'étais pas facile mais moi
s'emportant j'étais sûr que c'était sale
est bon qu'on commence à parler ensemble
quoi c'est vraiment parce que j'ai vu
dans ton regard et au niveau du visage
une attente qu'il n'y avait pas de
logique et j'ai fait un bon train mon
chum qui les ont relevé qu'il avait
serré entre maintenant on va faire la
fête ensemble
ça c'est sur sa chaîne ouais donc je
mets le lien dans la description et puis
directement aussi à la fin de la vidéo
vous aurez juste à cliquer dans dans la
vignette qui va être là dans quelques
secondes
ça va être super simple lorsqu'on va
faire je te lis ans après cuisiner vous
abonnez vous voir ça sur ma chaise
rendez vous tout de suite chez fast good
merci beaucoup abonnés volés qui nous
dit tout ce que vous en avez pensé
ciao
[Musique]